as a global health emergency is taking
hold America is moving forward with its
crucial once a decade census in March
the Census Bureau said an employee
tested positive for the new coronavirus
the worker didn't have contact with the
public but the incident is reinforcing
the bureau's need to collect information
over the Internet this isn't the
bureau's only challenge as it collects
surveys the 2020 census has been on the
Government Accountability offices
watchlist for three years those concerns
combined with pandemic driven
impediments could make 2020s count more
difficult to execute but the count must
move forward because it is a
foundational part of American governance
the census is very important because it
is the foundation of how political power
is distributed in this country and so
it's important to be counted and it's
not just that people being included but
it be included where they reside so that
political power can be equitably
distributed or accurately distributed
here's how the new dynamics are
reshaping 2020s count this year most
households received a letter rather than
a complete census form in the mail this
is the first census in which it will be
a widespread option to respond over the
Internet that's because the census
wanted to move toward online response in
light of the new coronavirus the
bureau's re-emphasizing the need to
respond online or by phone or by mail
without having to meet a census taker
this is the safest way to answer the
census and that could prove crucial as
the country hunkers down to increase
social distance and limit the spread of
the virus online response will limit the
amount of in-person enumeration needed
to count everyone which relates to
another major challenge facing 2020
census staffing staffing has been an
ongoing area of concern at the Census
Bureau that problem becomes most visible
at the local level one of the things
that's very important is to look at the
census down at almost a granular level a
very local level that's what's going to
make or break the census only about
two-thirds of the country responded to
the initial prompt for the 2010 census
and those numbers vary at the local
level for example about 74 percent of
Minnesotans responded to the censuses
first request but some counties in the
state had response rates below 40
percent
lower response rates mean that the
Census Bureau needs to send temporary
workers to knock on doors and request
responses in person but the need to
increase social distance will make it
harder to send field workers out to
track hard-to-reach populations and
others who don't respond for months the
Census Bureau struggled to recruit
enough temporary workers the GAO issued
this chart in February to show how far
behind the bureau had fallen the Census
Bureau disputed those findings saying
that they effectively met their staffing
goals but the bureau will still have to
deal with following response rates
that's because Americans in general have
become less likely to answer surveys
each census that I've been involved with
the bureau assumes a lower male response
rate than they've received in the
preceding census in part because of just
the complexity of counting people in
various living arrangements but in part
because a reduction in trust which
brings us to a third major challenge
facing 2020 census trust in 2019 the
Republican National Committee sent a
2020 congressional district census to a
number of households it was not an
official census the document asks about
political preferences and preferred news
sources none of which are asked on the
official census the questionnaire was
also much longer than the official
census and asked respondents to donate
money to process the document as
recently as March the Trump campaign
promoted the misleading prompt on
Facebook Facebook later removed the ads
citing the company's census interference
policy but experts say that the
lingering effects of confusing documents
like this could further depress response
rates in the country
census forums started arriving in
mailboxes in mid-march the Bureau must
report results to Congress no later than
December of 2020 some response time
tables could be shaken up the sabirah
monitors the situation and takes new
guidance from public health authorities
[Music]